can you tell the story of you trying to
get medical care or something i was five
months pregnant when we moved and when
you were born you were rh positive and
i'm rh negative so you get a shot so
that you don't abort your baby so when
we got to boston you have to have this
rh test at six months and so we were
moving right before i needed that when
we got to boston i call the healthcare
center at harvard and i say that you
know my husband's a new professor that
we just moved there and that i'm five
months pregnant and i need to see a
physician and they said it's a six month
waiting time to see a physician there
and you said you were pregnant yeah i
said i was pregnant and i'm like i
wonder what i could do to get in to see
a doctor bill clinton was the president
at that time and that must have had
something to do with my decision because
i phoned back and i said hi
i'm tammy peterson i just arrived here
from louisiana i need an appointment i'm
pregnant and they said well come right
in i'm like you [ __ ]